Guten Morgen, Tim.
Guten Morgen, Caldesi.
Was fällt dir da eigentlich zur Innovation ein?
Die Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer 450 vom 12. Januar 2020.
Heute ist Freitag der 13.
Oh!
Oh, echt? Stimmt. Freitag der 13. 2023. Okay. Das fängt ja gut an. Mal gucken, wie das so läuft.
Ja!
Das sind also diese goldenen Zwanziger.
Ja, hallo, Linus ist nicht da heute, weil der kann nicht.
Ja und deswegen haben wir passend zum Freitag den 13.
Sind ein Pech und müssen mit mir Vorlieb nehmen.
Es könnte schlimmeres geben. Es könnte schlimmeres geben. Ja, finde ich super, du springst ein, bist ja nicht das erste Mal da, sondern das dritte Mal. Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe,
habe ich das richtig in Erinnerung? Das ist korrekt. Okay, super. Mal gucken. Immerhin.
Das ist korrekt.
Einmal war ich schon korrekt, wir notieren das mal.
Man liegt ja nicht immer so ganz richtig mit den Voraussagen. Aber die goldenen Zwanziger sind auf jeden Fall fest gebucht, Leute.
Der Glaube versetzt Berge und man muss auch einfach ein bisschen durchhalten.
Die letzten goldenen Zwanziger haben auch ein bisschen auf sich warten lassen in der Dekade.
Könnte man so sehen, ja.
Ja, also so schlimm, also es kann ja immer noch schlimmer kommen. aber dann halt erst in 30 Jahren.
Davon bin ich ja schon noch zum Glück weit entfernt.
Ja, ich glaube, dass es auch als insbesondere Netzpolitik und Privacy-Aktivist keiner Veranstaltung.
Ja, die Innovation, das ist echt so eine Sache mit der Innovation. Deutschland, also du warst noch nie auf der CES, nehme ich mal an, ich auch nicht.
Bei der man dabei gewesen sein muss.
Ne, definitiv nicht. Die Rede ist von der Consumer Electronics Show, einer Fachmesse für Unterhaltungselektronik und genau so kommt es auch immer wieder rüber. Und das,
ist so ein bisschen so eine Blah Blah Blah Messe habe ich immer so den Eindruck.
Ja, da werden die Technologien vorgestellt, mit denen wir uns dann rumschlagen müssen die für Politiker einordnen und erklären müssen und auch erklären müssen, warum es eine blöde Idee ist vor allem.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie... Ich würde sagen, das deutsche Äquivalent dazu ist die IFA.
Was mal auf einer IFA? Das ist auch ganz schlimm. Hallen voll mit Fernsehern. Und jedes Jahr grübeln sie darüber nach, mit welchem Slogan man jetzt sozusagen das langweilige Produkt Fernseher neu verkaufen kann.
Dann ist es 3D, ja, was auch immer, 3D, ich meine 3D Fernseher hat sich einfach mal null durchgesetzt, wie auch sonst eigentlich nur irgendwo, dann ist es wieder keine Ahnung,
irgendwie jetzt 8K, gibt immer noch kein 4K Content, aber man muss sich jetzt schon ein 8K Fernseher kaufen und all so ein Quatsch.
Und so ist es, glaube ich, bei dieser CES auch. Auf jeden Fall hat die CES festgestellt, dass die richtig geile Innovationen in Deutschland passieren.
Volker Wissing ist ja auch die beste Innovation, die wir seit langem hatten.
Deswegen haben wir den auch gleich hingeschickt.
Und der hat da wirklich einen Preis bekommen für Innovation.
Was denn eigentlich? Was war der Grund? Der Grund war Innovation, die aus Deutschland kommt, die von amerikanischen Unternehmen, aber dort auf der CES präsentiert wird, weil das ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen so eine lokale Geschichte.
Also sicherlich auch in gewisser Hinsicht ein bisschen global, aber es ist halt sehr US zentriert, weil es geht ja um die Konsumer. Und das muss ich nochmal kurz nachschlagen.
Was war der Grund? Das war so ein Beispiel, interessant. Aber irgendwo war doch nochmal.
Ich glaube, landwirtschaftliche Technologien.
Hier diese, wo war denn das, das habe ich mir nicht notiert. Ah ja, genau. Für den Vergleich wurden,
also neben der Bundesrepublik erhielten 23 andere Länder die höchste Einstufung in dem Ranking der,
der Consumer Technology Association, dem Veranstalter der CES. Also wir sind nicht alleine, also nicht der einzige Champignon auf dem Markt.
Und für den Vergleich werden 40 Indikatoren in 17 Kategorien gemessen, darunter Breitbandzugang, Bildungssystem, Umweltqualität, Handelspolitik und Cybersicherheit.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob sie...
Welche dieser Bereiche würde dir jetzt besonders einfallen, wenn es um Deutschland geht?
Meinst du vielleicht, dass das eine Selbstauskunft war?
Also im Bereich Breitbandzugang habe ich echt so meine Probleme. Bildungssystemen, Deutschland digital,
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, was da die Innovation sein soll.
Umweltqualität?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was das mit Innovationen zu tun hat. und Cyber Sicherheit. Wie sieht es mit Cyber Sicherheit aus in Deutschland?
Was ist denn das, was Sie hier in der Cyber Security-Kontrolle.
Mitbekommen haben? Also, ich meine, wir sind ein wirklich gutes Experimentierfeld für das Auffinden von Sicherheitslücken oder auch um Beispiele zu liefern,
was man alles so falsch machen kann in der Cyber Security.
Grüße gehen raus nach Potsdam, wo man jetzt gerade die ganze Verwaltung ausschalten müssen, weil es da aber ein Problem ist.
Das ist vielleicht die Innovation. Mal wieder.
Ich würde sagen, wir fangen an mit Nachrichten vom letzten Jahr und den innovativen Forschungsergebnissen.
So viel zu Innovationen. Gucken wir mal lieber, was wir so an schlechten Nachrichten in diesem Jahr haben.
Des CCC.
Okay, was hat denn der CCC alles so schönes erforscht?
Es gibt ja so innovative Technologien und ganz viele Menschen würden Gesichtserkennungssoftware
und das Sammeln von biometrischen Daten und das Auswerten von biometrischen Daten dazuzählen.
Wir sagen ja schon seit Langem, dass das Sammeln von biometrischen Daten und auch das Erfassen eigentlich eine tickende Zeitbombe ist.
Also biometrische Daten sind relativ schwer abzuändern, wenn sie einmal erfasst wurden,
und dann natürlich auch relativ eindeutig zu verwenden, um Leute zu identifizieren. Und das US-Militär konnte es aber trotzdem nicht lassen und hat sich gedacht, na ja,
in einem Gebiet, in dem das sowieso schon ein ziemlich krisenhafter Zustand ist, es
ist sicherlich eine total gute Idee, alle Menschen biometrisch zu erfassen. Und das
ist in Afghanistan auch passiert und die wurden halt zur Identifikation von Personen genutzt,
Checkpoints bei der Fahndung nach Gesuchten, aber auch für die Zugangskontrolle für Ortskräfte.
Was ja aus einer gewissen Militärlogik heraus auch nachvollziehbar ist.
Ich meine, in der Mangelung von gültigen Ausweissystemen und anderen Überprüfungsmaßnahmen ist das ja sozusagen das einzige was du siehst.
Könnte man so sehen, ja. Aber gerade Ortskräfte sind natürlich auch besonders gefährdete
Personen, gerade wenn nicht alles so gut läuft. Und das Beispiel des Afghanistan ja ganz eindeutig.
Und bei dem etwas hastigen Abzug der NATO, ja, hat das US-Militär dann diese Geräte einfach mal
dargelassen.
Also wir reden im Wesentlichen von so Kamerasystemen, mit denen man halt ein Foto macht und die dann im Gerät eine Liste von biometrischen Merkmal- und Personenzuordnungen hat,
sodass man einfach sagen kann, wer bist denn du, klack, bumm, ja guck mal hier rein. Das sind glaube ich so Teile, die sitzt man so ein bisschen auf, so 3D-Brille.
Sieht so aus wie so eine große, wie so ja oder so wie beim Sehtest diese Dinge, die man sich da früher so
dran gehalten hat. So kann man sich das vorstellen. Genau.
Ja und...
Mhm. Genau. Ihres Erkennung primär.
Genau. Und die wurden halt zurückgelassen und das war ein Riesenproblem, weil die Taliban natürlich das genutzt haben, um dann halt Ortskräfte zu identifizieren, was ja auch irgendwie logisch ist als Konsequenz
der ganzen Geschichte. Aber es geht noch weiter. Sie haben nicht nur diese Geräte dort zurückgelassen, sondern die sind dann auch auf den gängigen,
Onlinehandelsplattformen auf einmal aufgetaucht. Und ein kleines Team aus CCC-Kreisen unter der Leitung von Kantorkl.
Zusammen mit Snoopy und Starbuck, hat sich dann mal so ein paar Gräte besorgt.
Und das war ziemlich schockierend, was die da vorgefunden haben. Wer das im Detail sich anhören will, es gibt einen Vortrag dazu, den verlinken wir euch auch in den Show Notes.
Aber um es ganz kurz zu machen, man konnte mit einem Standardpasswort,
was in der Dokumentation zu den Geräten zu finden ist, auf die gesamten Daten des Gerätes zugreifen.
Das, was diese Gruppe dort gefunden hat, waren 2632 Personen,
und deren hochsensible biometrische Daten.
Und das zeigt ganz offensichtlich, dass das US-Militär, aber auch die Bundeswehr, die
übrigens in Unterstützungseinsätzen auch diese Geräte benutzt hat, ein sehr lückenhaftes,
Risikobewusstsein für die Problematik und die Sensibilität von biometrischen Daten.
Hat. Und man muss auch hier nochmal sagen, es ist immer eine Frage der Zeit bei solchen Biometriedatenbanken,
bis die für irgendwelche illegitimen Interessen eingesetzt werden. Und das wird wahrscheinlich auch in Zukunft öfter mal passieren,
dass wenn irgendwelche Firmen Biometriedaten sammeln für irgendwelche Trainingszwecke,
dass die dann auch mal verloren gehen. Und das ist echt gefährlich, um es ganz kurz zu machen.
Genau, und das ist das Problem. Man ist natürlich jetzt auch ein technisch schlecht gelöstes Problem, weil klar.
Die Geräte sind natürlich alle lokal mit diesen Datenbanken ausgestattet, weil man kann nicht davon ausgehen, dass man irgendwie auf irgendein Internet zugreifen kann, was ja dann sowieso nochmal ein anderes Problem hat.
Das heißt, man lädt quasi immer aktualisierte Personenlisten in die Geräte rein, die dann halt ihre Scan machen, keine Ahnung, ob die noch andere Faktoren sich angeschaut haben, aber ich glaube, es ging hier,
primär um ihre Scan. So, die ist ja ausreichend eindeutig. Dann matcht man das halt auf diese,
Person und diese Zuordnung mit den biometrischen Merkmalen liegt da halt drauf. So, und dann werden
diese Geräte halt so zurückgelassen und niemand denkt darüber nach, dass da auch noch Daten drauf
Es wäre ja jetzt nicht so schwierig, da so einen Knopf anzubringen. Wenn man den zehn Sekunden lang drückt, dann wird irgendein interner Schlüssel weggeworfen und alle Daten sind sozusagen gelöscht.
Also entweder gibt es diesen Knopf nicht oder keiner hat ihn gedrückt.
Das ist also entweder eine Frage, ist die Technik für solche kritischen Situationen geeignet, um eben nicht noch Schaden im Nachgang zu erzeugen oder waren die,
Möglichkeiten technisch da, aber sind dann organisatorisch nicht genutzt worden,
weil es ihnen einfach zu schnell ging mit dem ganzen Kram. Naja, die Geräte sind halt jetzt auf eBay zu kaufen.
Da hat der Club die halt auch gefunden und sich angeschaut und 2632 Personen gefunden. Und das sind ja dann alles Personen, die eben mit dem Militär zusammenge- also,
nicht alle vielleicht, vielleicht wollten sie auch noch andere Leute erkennen, aber
vor allem, was sie ja gesagt haben, durch die Kontrolle, wer darf denn überhaupt Zugang
haben zu einem militärischen Bereich, sondern halt dann im Prinzip sind es sozusagen Kollaborationslisten.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt die Taliban mit diesen Geräten durch die Gegend laufen, können sie halt die Leute eindeutig identifizieren. Oder zumindest können sie identifizieren,
ja nicht welche Metadaten dann auch angezeigt werden, aber wahrscheinlich wenn da eh alle Daten drauf sind, dann wird ja auch grün oder rot auch noch mitzusehen sein.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen, weil die auch an Checkpoints eingesetzt wurden,
kann man wahrscheinlich auch noch relativ gut nachverfolgen, wo die Personen sich bewegt haben. Also anhand der Location der Geräte und ob sie da drin sind oder nicht.
Und von daher ist es auch problematisch, auch vor dem Hintergrund, dass diese ganzen, ich sag mal, Rettungsaktionen von Ortskräften auch nicht besonders gut laufen.
Und ja, braucht man eigentlich nichts mehr zu sagen, außer biometrische Daten sammeln
ist wirklich, wirklich immer eine sehr heikle Geschichte, die in der Regel dafür sorgt.
Dass Leute gefährdet werden. Also das Sammeln von biometrischen Daten ist irgendwie immer ein Riesenthema und total problematisch.
In dieser Afghanistan-Geschichte hat sich das ganz besonders gezeigt.
Aber das ist auch eine Geschichte von 2022 noch gewesen. Also der Dezember hat auch nicht besonders rühmlich geendet.
Da ist ein Projekt bekannt geworden der University of North Carolina.
Im Rahmen von diesem Projekt haben Forscherinnen ein Datenset von biometrischen Daten zusammengestellt,
was sie aus YouTube-Videos gescraped haben, von Transpersonen in ihrer Transition,
das heißt während der Hormontherapie, und die Veränderungen in den biometrischen Daten festzuhalten,
um Menschen zuverlässig in ihrer Transition anhand ihrer biometrischen Daten erkennen
zu können. Und das ist aus ganz, ganz vielen unterschiedlichen Perspektiven so falsch.
Also zum einen ist dieses Sammeln von den Daten passiert, ohne die Zustimmung der Menschen, die diese Videos kreiert haben, einzuholen.
Zum anderen ist die Motivation dahinter gewesen, was wirklich völlig absurd ist,
also das Forschungsprojekt wurde auch vom FBI finanziert, dass potenzielle Terroristinnen Hormonenpräparate einnehmen könnten, um ihre biometrischen Daten zu verändern.
Ernsthaft?
Okay. Und dann ...
Und das ist sozusagen so dieses, wie könnte man ein irgendwie trainiertes Daten, trainierte
AI täuschen? Na ja, man könnte ja Hormonpräparate einnehmen, um seine biometrischen Daten oder sein Äußeres
zu verändern. Und deswegen brauchen wir jetzt ein Datenset. In diesem Moment wird es aber auch nicht mehr so schlimm.
Das heißt, man wird jetzt schon des Terrorismus verdächtigt, wenn man 30 Tage lang hintereinander bei McDonald's gegessen hat.
Ja, so könnte man das auch sehen, aber ich glaube, die Konsequenz finde ich noch viel
schlimmer, weil gerade Transpersonen bei solchen, also bei Grenzübergängen und sonstigen Sachen sowieso schon sehr häufig diskriminiert werden und in vielen Ländern ja auch einfach sehr gefährdet sind.
Die Gewaltbereitschaft Transpersonen gegenüber nimmt extrem zu.
Und jetzt eine Software zu schaffen, die auch sehr eindeutig sagen kann,
diese Person nimmt Hormone ein und ist in einem Transitionszustand, sorgt natürlich dafür, dass trans Personen noch viel mehr gefährdet werden
und dass es sozusagen theoretisch eine Software gibt, die irgendwelche Regime oder sonstigeartig motivierte Personen dabei unterstützt.
Leute zu erkennen und das ist halt einfach ein Risikobewusstsein. Ich meine,
es ist ein wissenschaftliches Projekt gewesen, wo man sich natürlich auffragt, dass das auch ethisch überhaupt abgesegnet würde und dass es dann auch
noch von FBI gefundet wird, ist natürlich wirklich schon echt hart.
Also das ist wirklich, zeugt echt von Null Risikobewusstsein und auch irgendwie
Nullsensibilität für dieses Thema und auch für eine Orientierung der gesamten Wissenschaft,
auch um Transpersonen auch zu schützen vor allem.
Ich meine, wenn man sich anschaut, was so in den letzten Jahren im Bereich Gesichtserkennung,
und damit meine ich gar nicht mehr nur so Gesichtswiedererkennung, sondern überhaupt sagen wir mal das wissenschaftliche Verständnis, was man alles aus einem Gesicht heraus lesen kann.
Ich habe mich damit nicht zu intensiv beschäftigt, aber man sieht ja immer wieder interessante Paper und so Videos, wo so, man hat dann so zehn Slider, bei dem man sozusagen alle Merkmale eines Gesichts einfach feintunen kann.
Du kannst irgendwie ein Gesicht älter machen, du kannst ein Gesicht männlicher, weiblicher,
machen, du kannst ein Gesicht kränker oder gesünder aussehen lassen, symmetrischer, asymmetrischer.
Also all diese ganzen Faktoren, die dazu führen, dass eben Gesichter quasi komplett gemorft
werden von einem Gemützustand auch in den anderen, also optimistischerer Blick, depressiver Blick, also all diese ganzen Faktoren sind mittlerweile bekannt.
Das ist sozusagen nichts Besonderes und man sieht das ja auch bei diesen ganzen Fake-Videos,
dass man ja mühelos von einem Videobild auf ein erzeugtes Videobild die Optik des Gesichts ändern kann, aber dabei eben sozusagen alle Elemente, auf die es einen in dem Moment ankommt,
erhalten bzw. dann eben auch feintunen kann. Und das muss man uns irgendwie auch klarmachen,
dass diese ganze biometrische Erfassung mehr oder weniger ein Abfallprodukt jetzt sein wird unserer ubiquitär vorhandenen Bilderflut von Menschen. Es gibt ja kaum noch Leute, die nicht irgendwie
massig Bilder von sich erzeugen, einfach weil jeder Smartphone in der Hand tatsächlich,
gemacht werden. Vielleicht nicht jeder postet, uns gibt natürlich auch ein paar Leute, die da ein bisschen zurückhaltender sind, aber wir sehen ja auch, wie viele Leute da überhaupt,
nicht zurückhaltend sind. Und da das eben alles in der Öffentlichkeit ist, wird es eben auch alles gescannt werden. Und die eigentliche Frage ist halt jetzt, wenn man sozusagen diese Datenflut jetzt,
noch hat und die Erfassung sozusagen so einfach ist, was kann man jetzt noch regulieren, was kann kann man jetzt noch überhaupt verbessern.
Naja, und ich glaube, man muss halt auch einfach ganz grundsätzlich darüber sprechen, ob man diese
Technologien auch teilweise überhaupt bauen will. Also, weil es halt wirklich häufig halt dramatische Konsequenzen hat und auch wirklich viel Raum für Missbrauch einfach da ist. Und ich glaube,
das ist einfach so ein Thema, wo man so ganz generell darüber sprechen sollte. Also, unabhängig davon, ob Bilder online verfügbar sind, wie jetzt bei diesen Transpersonen, wo man sagen könnte, naja,
ihr habt das halt online auf YouTube gestellt, deswegen konnten wir es halt scrapen. Es ist halt immer was anderes, ob du es halt auf YouTube gestellt hast oder ob du eine wirklich eine,
konzentrierte Sammlung der Sachen hast, wo dann drauf steht, hier sind übrigens X drin, weil dann können natürlich Leute darauf zugreifen und sagen, okay, dann machen wir jetzt mal daraus irgendwie ein Erkennungssystem.
Klar, das ist eine ethische Frage, aber man weiß auch, dass es einfach passieren wird.
Ja, natürlich, aber ich glaube trotzdem sollte man trotzdem ab und an mal so die Frage stellen, so wollen wir das überhaupt und dann hat natürlich auch
unter welchen Bedingungen. Das ist eigentlich eine schöne Überleitung. Es gibt ja auf EU-Eben
zum Beispiel die Bestrebung, ein AI-Act zu schaffen, also eine Regulierung, die regeln soll,
wie künstliche Intelligenz gebaut wird, verwendet werden darf und so weiter, Einstufung vornimmt,
was auch so Hochrisiko AI-Anwendung angeht und welche besonderen Auflagen dann dafür gelten.
Wir hatten große Hoffnung, dass dies auch schaffen, dieses ganze Thema,
biometrische Massenüberwachung und Gesichtserkennung auch im Rahmen vom AI,
Act zu regeln. Im Koalitionsvertrag hat man uns versprochen, dass.
Biometrische Erfassung im öffentlichen Raum bei flächendeckender Videoüberwachung,
nicht passieren wird und verhindert werden wird und dass weiterhin ein Recht auf Anonymität im öffentlichen Raum gewahrt werden soll und,
dementsprechend hatte man natürlich auch gehofft, dass sich die Bundesregierung entsprechend im Rat einsetzt gegen biometrische Massenüberwachung und die,
Bundesregierung ist wieder mal die Bundesregierung und wir treffen mal wieder Volker Wissing, der im Ministerrat dieses Gesetz mit beraten hat. Und die,
Bundesregierung ist zwar gegen biometrische Massenüberwachung, aber halt nicht so richtig. Und zwar ist rausgekommen, dass das, was jetzt
abgestimmt wurde im Rat sozusagen nachträgliche Analysen mit biometrischen Daten erlaubt. Das heißt, wenn ich ein Überwachungsvideo aufgenommen habe, darf,
ich zwar nicht live die Gesichter analysieren und mappen und identifizieren, aber wenn ich ein Überwachungsvideo habe, darf ich eine Software im Nachhinein darüber laufen lassen und mithilfe
von biometrischen Daten die Personen, die daran beteiligt waren oder in der Situation waren,
identifizieren. Was halt nicht so wirklich...
Eine Einschränkung ist.
Nein, also...
Nein. Vor allem dann hat man auch noch mehr Zeit. Also live wäre ja schwierig, aber so danach ist einfacher, weil dann hat man ja sozusagen alle Ruhe der Zeit und Computing Power, um das dann machen zu können.
Ja, und das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch so, wahrscheinlich wird es dann das nächste,
was dann die Sicherheitsmenschen sagen, ist dann so, ja, dann müssen wir jetzt auch Überwachungsvideo, Vorratsdaten speichern, weil es könnte ja sein, dass gegeben dem Fall, dass vielleicht ja doch was passiert ist, wir dann da Software drüber laufen lassen.
Also das ist insgesamt sehr, sehr enttäuschend gewesen, was die Bundesregierung da abgeliefert hat.
Wir gehen jetzt sozusagen, also das war die Abstimmung im Ministerinnenrat, und im Frühjahr geht es dann in den wohlbekannten Trilog, also wo das Gesetz dann zwischen Kommission, Parlament und Rat ausgehandelt wird.
Was war denn die Position vom Parlament?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die schon stattgefunden hat. Ich meine nämlich nicht.
Also es muss ja eine Position des Parlaments geben, bevor es zum Trilog kommen kann.
Ja, aber Frühjahr ist ja noch ein bisschen hin.
Ja, okay, gut, kann sein.
Also das kann ich dir nicht sagen, wie das da genau aussieht.
Aber du hast einen guten Punkt genannt, Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ich finde mal gar nicht so sehr, dass das jetzt hier nur ein passender Vergleich ist, das auch, sondern das kann sehr gut sein, dass das eigentlich auch mal genau darunter fällt.
Weil das ist es ja. Das ist Daten auf Vorrat sozusagen. Also alles erstmal filmen,
um dann später das in Ruhe auswerten zu können. Das heißt, hier müssten im Prinzip dieselben
Diskussionsansätze drangestellt werden, ja so Quick Freeze-mäßig. Also das ist das Problem,
also Videoaufzeichnung, das wird halt dann gemacht überall. Bezog sich das jetzt eigentlich auf,
alle private auch oder nicht? Okay, also privat ist sozusagen nochmal ein anderes Problem, ob.
Es ging konkret um Videoüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum.
Man das dann darf und das würde ich halt meinen, das sollte dann eben genauso verboten werden,
aber natürlich auch gerade was den öffentlichen Raum betrifft. Das heißt ja, dass man Vorratsdaten anlegt im öffentlichen Raum. So, also eigentlich noch krasser als das jetzt im Telekommunikationsbereich,
Bereich ist, weil dem kann man sich ja in gewisser Hinsicht noch entziehen.
Das ist auch ziemlich schwierig, aber im öffentlichen Raum will man sich ja eigentlich unbeobachtet,
bewegen können. Und wenn halt klar ist, dass jede Kamera, die irgendwo was aufzeichnet, das dann lange
vorhält und dann wird im Zweifelsfall halt da nachgeschlagen, dann erlaubt das dann eben
wieder genau diese Bilder oder Abbilder zu schaffen, dass man halt Bewegungsanalysen nachträglich machen kann. Ich verstehe natürlich, was hier die Argumentation ist.
Die Argumentation ist, ja, jetzt haben wir diesen Platz überwacht und dann Terroranschlag und dann wollen wir halt irgendwie den Terroristen fangen. Und das wäre doch mal schön, wenn man da irgendwie Gesichtserkennung drüber laufen lassen könnte. Das ist sozusagen immer das Ding. Aber die Frage ist, was ist dann eben das Missbrauchspotenzial? Und wie,
wir das ja eben so schön gesehen haben bei diesen militärischen Geräten in Afghanistan, wenn die Daten halt erstmal rumliegen und wenn die Anwendung von solcher Auswertungssoftware einfach ist und das wird es in zunehmendem Maße sein wie eben Clearview.
Dann muss zumindest auch klar sein, dass es sich hierbei um eine Rechtsverletzung handelt,
weil wenn es das nicht ist, dann ist sozusagen der Missbrauch dieser Daten natürlich Tür und Tor
geöffnet.
Man muss auch sagen, auch bei sehr vielen Argumenten, die die Sicherheitsbehörden anbringen,
muss man auch häufig sagen, dass viele Sachen, es gibt ungefähr noch so 20 Schritte in der Ermittlungsarbeit, die man tun könnte, bevor man zu solchen Maßnahmen greifen muss.
Da gibt es auch sehr interessante Studien zu, wie zum Beispiel, gerade wenn wir über Touristinnen sprechen, wie sich das entwickelt und dass zum Beispiel viele,
terroristisch motivierte Taten entstehen. Und bevor sie entstehen, die Täterinnen, und da meisten sind es ja Täter,
häufig zum Beispiel gewalttätig ihren PartnerInnen gegenüber sind oder ähnliches. Also da gibt es sehr viele Indikatoren, die auch sozusagen.
Bereits schon Auffälligkeiten sind, wo man halt schon frühzeitig intervenieren kann,
ohne dass man überhaupt irgendeine Form von Massenüberwachung braucht, um dem nachzugehen. Aber das mal nur so am Rande.
Also das ist auch in unserer Chat-Kontrollendebatte immer wieder Thema. Wie erkennt man eigentlich solche Taten und Täter?
Und das ist halt ein Thema. Und ich glaube, was auch interessant ist, einfach zu sagen, es gibt keine Erfassung,
also es gibt keine Datenbasis von Straferfolgungsbehörden dazu, wann Ermittlungen an fehlenden Daten gescheitert sind.
Also die sagen immer, wir brauchen mehr Daten, aber sie können nicht sagen, wir konnten,
Ermittlungen X nicht zu Ende führen, weil das Datum gefehlt hat sozusagen.
Also das ist nicht belegt, das ist jetzt nicht in der Statistik erfasst.
Also behauptet wird es, aber es ist sozusagen nicht belegt.
Genau, also es ist irgendwie immer so ein Bauchgefühl und das Bauchgefühl sagt einem.
Geschweige denn, dass man mal Studien dazu gemacht hätte.
Dass mehr Kompetenzen mehr gut sind.
Mehr Kompetenz, mehr gut. So sieht's aus. Gut, kommen wir mal zu einem anderen Problem, das gerade sehr präsent ist, nämlich das,
Problem der Content Moderation. Und da müssen wir natürlich jetzt vor allem mal wieder über
unsere Freunde reden, die Social Networks, vor allem Twitter. Weil Elon Musk, seitdem er da
irgendwie mit einem wilden Besen rumkehrt, vor allem nicht nur, aber vor allem auch die Leute rausgeschmissen hat, die halt Content Moderation machen in einzelnen Ländern. Ich weiß nicht, gibt es überhaupt noch welche?
Also ich glaube, in Brasilien sind fast alle rausgeschmissen aus dem Content Moderation Team.
Und das ist natürlich besonders interessant. Irgendwie fühlt sich ja 2023 an wie die Wiederkehr. Und also für den Kontext in Brasilien wurden diverse Regierungsgebäude gestürmt und das wurde natürlich, wie so häufig, auch über Telegram zum Beispiel organisiert, aber auch über andere Kanäle.
Die Wiederkehr von 21. Wiederkehr.
Und im Zusammenhang mit dieser Content-Moderation-Geschichte und Twitter,
hat man auch irgendwie schon den ersten Punkt von Problemen von Content-Moderation, weil Content-Moderation ist super komplex und hängt sehr davon ab, ob den Content-Moderatoren
die Probleme, die Debatte, der Slang, was auch immer in den Ländern bekannt ist, in dem sie den Content moderieren. Und dementsprechend wird ja dann auch
Meldungen nachgegangen. Und bei Twitter liegt natürlich jetzt die Vermutung nahe, dass dadurch, dass das Content-Moderation-Team in Brasilien de facto nicht vorhanden ist,
konnte Twitter einfach in diesem Momentum gar nicht angemessen auf diesen Sturm der
Regierungsgebäude reagieren. So, das vielleicht einmal zu der Brasilien-Geschichte.
Mhm.
Wobei es jetzt auch nicht nur Twitter eine Rolle gespielt hat, sondern da geht es um,
Telegram, da geht es um Facebook, da geht es im Prinzip um alle Chatlines, also da kam ja alles zum Einsatz.
Und Facebook hat zwar gesagt, wir waren da auch irgendwie schon im Vorfeld dabei, aber am Ende war es eigentlich auf allen Plattformen möglich, diese Informationen zu bekommen.
Und das hat sich ja irgendwie über Wochen aufgebaut und das war ja im Prinzip so ein 6. Januar recreated vom ganzen Playbook her und haben wir dann alle gesehen,
irgendwie Busladungen von irgendwie merkwürdigen Leuten sind dort aufgetaucht
und haben dann halt irgendwie erst mal so in Polizeibegleitung, also die Polizei hat die dann da so hinbegleitet und teilweise noch, also sich nicht unbedingt aktiv daran
gehindert und dann sind die halt irgendwie so auf die Regierungsgebäude losgegangen, haben dann Oscar Niemeyers preisgeprügte Architektur erst mal entglast. Immerhin wurden sie danach auch noch in großen Mengen festgenommen. Das hat ja irgendwie in den USA nicht so gut funktioniert.
Aber das Ganze lässt natürlich jetzt irgendwie drauf blicken, wie ist es denn eigentlich mit dieser ganzen Content Moderation. Wenn man mal bei Facebook schaut, also bei Facebook gibt es jetzt,
gerade den Fall, dass die Firma, die für Facebook in Schwarzafrika die Moderation gemacht hat.
Das ist sozusagen outgesourced, obwohl es sich dabei auch um ein amerikanisches Unternehmen halt handelt, aber die haben dann irgendwie in Kenia, glaube ich, ein Team gehabt, die sozusagen für das Afrikanische, also alles was sozusagen südlich der Sahara ist, für all diese Länder,
die Moderation gemacht haben. Und das Unternehmen stand wohl auch ohnehin schon unter Druck,
weil so die Arbeitsbedingungen wohl nicht die besten waren, die Bezahlungen wohl auch nicht.
Da ist die Rede von irgendwie so zwei Dollar die Stunde und so was in der Größenordnung. Und Mitarbeiter, die dort gearbeitet haben, haben wohl so diese Tätigkeit wesentlichen als psychische Folter beschrieben. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt sozusagen sich ausschließlich auf die,
inhaltliche Arbeit bezieht oder auf die Arbeitsbedingungen in diesem Unternehmen dann auch noch zusätzlich.
Aber das kennt man ja, das im Prinzip, ich meine, Kotet Bollereysch, musst du dir mal vorstellen,
was du da für einen Scheiß zu sehen bekommst.
Ja, und ich glaube, was halt auch, es wird halt massiv unterschätzt.
Also es kommt auch immer auf die Firma drauf an, wie das geregelt ist,
wie Contentmoderatorinnen bezahlt werden. Häufig werden die auch auf Basis darauf bezahlt, wie viel Content sie moderieren. Und das Problem, was du hier hast, ist halt einfach Facebook und Co benutzen natürlich irgendwie künstliche Intelligenz, um das irgendwie.
Moderieren.
Um halt ihre Seiten nach bestimmten Content und bestimmten Stichworten durchzukämmen
und irgendwie Hasskommentaren und so weiter. Und dann kommen natürlich noch die Meldungen dazu. Und dann hast du halt unterbezahlte Content-Moderatorinnen,
die zum Beispiel ja auch keine psychische Betreuung bekommen für dieses ganze Zeug, was sie sich da antun müssen, die davon abhängig sind, dass sie möglichst viel auch irgendwie schaffen.
Das heißt irgendwie, ich finde Hasskommentare lesen manchmal schon sehr
belastend und jetzt stell dir vor jemand hat dich an deinen Rechner gefesselt und du musst nur Hasskommentare lesen und musst es auch einschätzen, ob das jetzt,
problematisch ist oder eher nicht so problematisch. Also das ist wirklich wahnsinnig, eine wahnsinnige Arbeit, die die Menschen da leisten und das,
benötigt eigentlich auch sehr viel Fingerspitzengefühl und Wissen, was ich
halt vorhin auch schon meinte, über die aktuelle Situation vor Ort. Und weil wir,
jetzt so Content Moderation als als das große Überthema haben, Content Moderation
ist ja jetzt kein neues Thema. Also mit diesem Problem sind wir ja eigentlich,
konfrontiert, seitdem es große Social Media Plattformen gibt.
Also es hat ein bisschen gedauert, bis man das gesehen hat.
Es hat ein bisschen gedauert, ja.
Weil am Anfang war das ja alles noch ganz toll. Ja, am Anfang war das ganz toll.
Twitter und so war ein Blumengarten. Weil sich da ja sozusagen nur die Aufgeschlossenen getummelt haben und sich kreativ haben ausüben können. und dann war man dann sehr überrascht, als die Leute dann irgendwann böse wurden.
Ja, und ich glaube, das ist ja auch so eine Historie, wo man viel gelernt hat, wie man
sozusagen, welchen Content man bloggt und basierend auf welchen Sachen. Also dass halt sozusagen zum Beispiel es nicht sinnvoll ist, wenn nur das amerikanische,
Headquarter sagt, das ist gut, das ist schlecht, das ist gut, das ist schlecht.
Am besten noch den übersetzten Content von einer möglichst weit weg befindlichen Location zu moderieren,
und überhaupt keinen Kontext zu haben. Also Contentmoderation funktioniert halt immer nur mit Kontextualisierung.
Superlokal.
Ja, also das ist halt wirklich ein Thema und alle Versuche auch das komplett mit künstlicher Intelligenz zu lösen, lösen, führen halt auch einfach zu massiven Overblocking von Sachen. Also das ist auch eine,
Problematik, die sehr wohl bekannt ist und auch eine große Sorge. Ich war vor ein paar Wochen gerade
in Wien bei der OSZE, wo es wirklich um dieses Thema ging, halt AI-basierte Content Moderation
Tools und ihre Gefahr für Freedom of
Expression, aber auch Freedom of the Media. Und,
da ist auch wirklich eine große Sorge da, dass es halt auch einfach gefährlich
werden kann, wenn man halt einfach irgendwie verstichwortete Sachen hat, aber auch
zum Beispiel viele Dinge von irgendwelchen,
Demos, die auch irgendwie, wo auch Gewalt im Spiel ist, da kann es natürlich auch
sein, dass solche automatisierten Content-Moderation Tools erstmal
anspringen und dann diese ganze Dokumentation von dem, was da passiert,
einfach erstmal weg ist, was halt auch ein Riesenproblem ist.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall kein einfach zu lösendes Problem, weil wir eben auch wirklich,
immer in diesem Spannungsfeld von auf der einen Seite möchte man nicht overblocken, aber auf der anderen Seite will man auch nicht nicht blocken.
Also man ist ja sozusagen beides kein Idealzustand, da gibt es nicht irgendwie so, man muss unbedingt in die eine Richtung gehen, weil nur da ist es richtig, sondern wenn man halt einfach,
zu viel verhinderst, dann schränkt es halt irgendwie ein meinungsfreiheitsschwieriges Wort geworden.
Also das kann dann sozusagen entweder intentional oder eben zufällig legitime und vielleicht
eben auch wichtige und überlebenswichtige Informationen unterdrücken, die man eben eigentlich sehen wollen würde oder zumindest einen Teil der Gesellschaft sehen möchte.
Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn du sagst, ja okay, dann schrauben wir das halt wieder zurück, dann bist du in der Situation, wo dann eben wieder 80 Prozent nur noch Hate und Spam und Scam ist.
Und da irgendwie eine goldene Mitte zu finden, ist schwierig, weil man könnte ja auch fast
sagen, das Problem lässt sich nicht lösen, dann müssen wir also einfach die Quelle des Problems abschalten. Und das kann es ja dann auch wieder nicht sein, weil dann hätten wir überhaupt gar kein Social Media und ehrlich gesagt so schlimm Social Media ist, so richtig so ohne, wäre,
Wird auch nix, oder?
Ja, und ich glaube, man muss da dann auch irgendwie ein bisschen darüber reden, warum Menschen denken, dass so was in Ordnung ist.
Also im Sinne von Hasskommentare oder Ähnliches. Und das ist dann wieder ein sehr, sehr komplexes Problem, in dem man sich da befindet.
Ich glaube, was man auch nicht außer Acht lassen darf bei dieser Content-Moderationsgeschichte, ist natürlich, dass Content-Moderation derzeit von Unternehmen gemacht wird,
die natürlich wirtschaftliche Interessen haben. Das heißt, die haben natürlich auch ein Interesse, sich in bestimmten Regionen zu halten.
Und deswegen fällt gegebenenfalls Content-Moderation auch unterschiedlich aus.
Und das ist dann auch wieder, was man dann so in Frage stellen kann. wie gut ist eigentlich, dass so eine Geschichte in der Hand von wirtschaftlichen Akteurinnen ist?
Und wenn sie in der Hand von wirtschaftlichen Akteurinnen ist, müssen wir es dann nicht irgendwie enger regulieren, wie das ausfallen darf oder nicht ausfallen darf. Also zum Beispiel,
dieses ganze Thema, das ist ja auch von Plattform zu Plattform sehr unterschiedlich. Was passiert
eigentlich, wenn ein Kommentar gelöscht wird oder geblockt wird, gibt es dann eine angemessene,
Beschwerdestelle und reagiert diese Beschwerdestelle dann auch und kann man irgendwie dem ganzen
widersprechen und führt das dann auch dazu, dass zum Beispiel der Account wieder freigegeben
wird oder halt auch nicht. Haben wir ja auch bei Twitter total schön gesehen, als die ganzen Journalistinnen einfach,
geblockt wurden, weil sie halt kritische Berichterstattung durchgeführt haben.
Und das ist halt so wieder diese ganze Problematik. Es obliegt halt dieser riesengroßen kapitalistischen Plattform,
was denn dann okay ist an Spielregeln auf ihrer Plattform und was nicht. Was halt auch...
Ich meine, die Alternative wäre ja zu sagen, man bräuchte jetzt sozusagen einen staatlichen
Mechanismus, das zu machen. Der wird zwangsläufig, also das wird sich schon technisch nicht lösen lassen. Und außerdem will man auch genau das wiederum auch nicht, dass das jetzt so eine staatliche Hoheitsaufgabe ist.
Das willst du auch nicht.
Von daher würde ich sagen, das ist schon okay.
Gut, man kann sich jetzt fragen, ob so ein Outsourcing okay ist oder nicht. Aber das hat, glaube ich, in diesem Zusammenhang hier auch der Berichterstattung, die wir hier aufgreifen, eher so arbeitsrechtliche Gründe und nicht per se.
Weil die benutzen ja am Ende trotzdem die Tools von Facebook oder wem auch immer.
Also wie schon erwähnt, also hier kommt mittlerweile, ich kann es fast nicht mehr hören, den Begriff. Also, sagen wir mal Machine Learning. Weil mit Intelligenz hat das jetzt nicht so viel zu tun, sondern das sind halt einfach
die Software-Algorithmen, die jetzt in den letzten Jahren so erfolgreich waren, die man jetzt gemeint als künstliche Intelligenz bezeichnet, das ist halt Maschine des Lernens.
Das heißt, man hat halt im Prinzip so permanentes Trainingsmuster, das heißt Fotos, Videos,
Text, all das, was irgendwie klar gefleckt wird, sagen wir mal, ist hier so ein typischer Jihad-Aufruf oder was auch immer oder so typische Hasskommentare, die halt abgesetzt werden.
Fließen die in diesen Lernprozess rein und kriegen so das Tag mit. Das sind Dinge, die wir nicht sehen wollen.
Das heißt, die Maschine lernt dadurch immer besser, von welcher Art so eine Nachricht ist. Das ist natürlich kein kontextuelles Lernen. Das ist immer nur das ist ein, das ist ein.
Aber das ist sozusagen kein Lernen, was in dem Kontext der Kommunikation richtig funktioniert.
Das wäre dann sozusagen die eigentliche Intelligenz-Ebene.
Da kommen wir sicherlich auch gleich nochmal drauf, wenn wir über Chat-GPT reden. Das ist im Prinzip genau deren Versprechen, diese Kontextualisierung dort richtig zu machen.
Aber das sind sozusagen die Werkzeuge, mit denen die arbeiten. Trotzdem wäre es natürlich sinnvoll, nicht eine staatliche Durchführung, aber so eine staatliche Drübersicht zu haben.
Zu haben. Also dass es sozusagen so eine Berichtspflicht gibt, dass man auch Stichproben testen kann. Diesen Content kann man nicht. Das ist so viel und schlimm noch dazu. Du,
kannst ja nicht die komplette Arbeit, die diese Teams machen, dann auch noch überprüfen, aber es muss zumindest die Möglichkeit geben zu sagen, wir wollen jetzt hier mal stichpunktmäßig rein gehen und zeigen lassen, was wird aussortiert und was wird durchgelassen, um das sozusagen,
überprüfen zu können.
Ja, und das ist ja auch interessant. Ich glaube, das war auch schon mal Thema im Zusammenhang mit dem,
deutschen Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz, dass die dann vielleicht reporten, wie viele Sachen gemeldet wurden und wie viel sie runtergenommen haben und so weiter und so fort. Aber zum Beispiel wenig Daten darüber vorlagen,
wie viele Sachen widerrechtlich runtergenommen wurden. Also sozusagen, im Fachschulangang sagt man ja dann
gerne Overblocking. Also wenn diese Erkennungsmechanismen sowohl durch Menschen als auch durch Maschinen dazu geführt haben, dass Content geblockt,
wurde, der eigentlich nicht hätte geblockt werden dürfen. Und das ist
natürlich die Problematik. Also man muss da dann halt auch ein sehr fein eingestelltes Reporting hinbekommen, um das auch rechtssicher zu gestalten.
Ja, bleibt ein schwieriges Feld die Quartet Moderation, aber es gibt eine Gruppe bei Access
die sich mit dieser Frage generell mal auseinandergesetzt hat.
Ja, genau. Es gibt ein Prinzipienpapier, das sich damit beschäftigt, wie Content- und.
Plattformverwaltung in Krisensituationen aussehen kann. Ich glaube, das ist im letzten Jahr wahrscheinlich auch so sehr deutlich geworden mit dem Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine und den vielen Falschinformationen, aber auch die Falschinformationen, die im Hinblick auf die,
Corona-Krise in Umlauf gebracht wurden. Und das ist halt, wir sehr häufig in Situationen enden,
wo es sehr, sehr schwierig ist, das zu differenzieren. Und auch für die Plattformen und die Situation, die sich da auch jeden Tag ergeben, immer sehr anspruchsvoll sind.
Und Access Now hat mit diversen weiteren zivilgesellschaftlichen Organisationen
einen Guide aufgesetzt, was dann passieren muss, damit man auch in Krisensituationen oder in Krisenzeiten grundrechtskonforme Content Moderation durchführen kann.
Und da gibt es halt grundlegende Prinzipien, aber halt auch zum Beispiel,
dass es bestimmte Protokolle gibt, um Szenarien zu evaluieren.
Und vor allen Dingen, dass es auch eine regelmäßige Evaluierung von allen Maßnahmen gibt, auch eine Beobachtung der Situation.
Um zu schauen, ob das immer noch grundrechtskonform ist
oder ob jetzt gerade wirklich Overblocking stattfindet, weil das nicht mehr ins Bild passt.
Das ist ein sehr aufwendiger Prozess, der sehr viel Know-how und Zeit drumrum bedeutet.
Wer das im Detail interessiert, kann sich diesen Guide angucken. Ich glaube, das wird weiterhin ein sehr spannendes Thema werden.
Man sieht es jetzt sehr gut an Twitter, was an Fallouts passiert, wenn Content-Moderatorinnen vermehrt rausgeschmissen werden.
Und man sieht aber auch natürlich an vielen Gesetzgebungen, die sozusagen mehr Screening für zweifelhaften Content fordern, dass da auch die Personen, die diese Contentmoderation machen, müssen überhaupt nicht mitgedacht werden.
Ja, und wenn wir gerade über Überwachung von Content sprechen, unser Innovations-Champion.
Also generell auch nicht im Ausland.
Deutsche Bundeswehr hat er ja auch irgendwie so ein bisschen was mit Überwachung gemacht und auch noch im Inland, was ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht deren Aufgabe war.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber rechtlich ist das im Inland noch viel fragwürdiger als im Ausland.
Ja, also es gibt natürlich Organisationen, die bestimmte Kritik an ihrer Arbeit nicht so gerne sehen. Unter anderem auch die Bundeswehr. Und es gab, ich glaube es war ja genau, schon 20, muss schon 2020 gewesen sein,
ein Projekt, das hieß Propaganda Awareness und es ging hier um IT-gestützte
Erfassung von Akteuren und Quellenlisten, die propagandistische Aktivitäten,
durchführen, wohl bemerkt gegen die Bundeswehr. Und die Bundeswehr hat Maschinen, also mit Hilfe von KI, Webseiten, also wahrscheinlich einfach Schlagwort-Suche gemacht. Also ich würde tatsächlich wirklich interessieren,
ob Geld für diese KI geflossen ist oder ob sie da irgendwas neues entwickelt oder gebaut haben, das wäre schon interessant. Aber genau, sie haben also nach Propaganda-Content gesucht und.
Es ist nicht das erste Mal, dass so etwas passiert. Das Zentrum für politische Schönheit
ist natürlich sofort aufs Radar gekommen. Die haben eine wunderschöne Aktion gemacht 2020,
die hieß, wo sind die Waffen? Im Rahmen dessen haben sie einen Container vom Bundestag aufgestellt,
und dazu aufgefordert, die verschwundenen Waffen im Bestand dieser Bundeswehr wieder zurückzugeben,
was ich eigentlich total nett finde. Besonders lustig ist, dass sie auch sehr echtsehende Briefe an die entsprechenden Standorte der Bundeswehr geschickt haben und dazu aufgefordert haben.
…
Und ja, so sind sie auf das Radar des Projektes Propaganda Awareness geraten.
Und was dann passiert ist, ist auch wirklich völlig wahnsinnig. Es gab dann wirklich ein systematisches Monitoring, also eine systematische Überwachung im Inneren,
sozusagen durch die Bundeswehr, des Zentrums für politische Schönheit.
Ja.
Dürften die das überhaupt?
Also der ehemalige Präsident des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes sagt, das ist rechtlich sehr, sehr fragwürdig,
und greift halt auch extrem in die informationelle Selbstbestimmung ein. Also sehr offensichtlich.
Gemeintes Hans-Jürgen Papier, der ehemalige Präsi.
Genau, der ausreizt sich immer mal wieder und ist ein ganz kluger Kopf. Tja.
Mehr Überwachung von allem ist ja irgendwie immer das Ziel.
Dass es so etwas gibt und es so viel sich um das alles sagt. Und das ist wirklich super. Ich glaube, wir sind auch schon im Moment auch ein bisschen.
Es ist irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ich bin so desillusioniert. Also ich habe immer so das Gefühl, also ja, bei allem habe ich so das Gefühl, durch die
Hintertür ist es immer dann noch mehr Überwachung.
Bisschen mehr mit der Musik machen. Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr überraschend, weil es wir ja auch so haben. Aber es ist natürlich ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen In gewisser Hinsicht, ich denke diese Bestrebungen gab es schon immer und das einzige, was sich,
wirklich geändert hat, ist der Preis. Überwachung im großen Stil. Wenn man mal zurückblickt in der,
DDR, so die Stasi, das war schon so eine Organisation, die an einer sehr langen Leine,
gehalten wurde. Dort war es quasi Staatsräson, möglichst viel Daten zu
sammeln. Und was haben die nicht alles gesammelt? Also abgesehen davon, dass sie natürlich alles, was sich irgendwie so ohne weiteres bürokratisch einsammeln lässt und Zugriff, wo man Zugriff erhalten kann auf Einwohnerlisten etc.
Also wer arbeitet wo etc. Das waren natürlich Informationen, die waren mehr oder weniger unmittelbar da, weil sie ohnehin Teil des Staatswissens waren und quasi für den normalen Betrieb erforderlich waren. Aber sie sind ja dann,
auch richtig weite Wege gegangen und haben dann so von Leuten, die sie eben besonders beobachten,
wollten, auch Geruchspromen gesammelt. Es sind ja so Geruchspromen-Archive gefunden worden,
sodass man dann im Zweifelsfall halt auch Hunde und so weiter auf bestimmte Personen ansetzen kann.
Das meine ich aber gerade, diese Ideen sind da. Und dass das früher so wenig getan wurde.
Bringen diese Startups nicht auf Ideen.
Ist eine reine Kostenfrage gewesen. Und jetzt sind wir halt an einem Punkt angekommen, wir sind schon lange an mehreren Punkten angekommen, wo sich diese Preise immer wieder dramatisch gesenkt haben. Erstmal das Speichern von Daten, also überhaupt so viele Daten irgendwo,
abzulegen, war lange lange Zeit ein Problem und ist dann so Ende der 80er Jahre mit dem
Aufkommen von großen Festplatten irgendwann auch gar kein Thema mehr gewesen. So, jetzt haben wir eben Kameras, die immer billiger werden.
Von Speichermengen brauchen wir jetzt schon mal gar nicht mehr zu reden, da gibt es im Prinzip beliebig viel Speicher. Also wenn du irgendwie heute einen Peterbite speichern willst, dann ist das irgendwie finanzierbar.
Das kriegst du irgendwie zusammen, zumindest wenn das Interesse an sich erstmal groß genug ist.
Daran scheitert es am Ende nicht wirklich. Abgesehen davon, dass die Speicher ja sowieso weltweit rumliegen und man einfach nur übers Internet irgendwo verschlüsselt hinschreiben
könnte und dann hat man diesen Speicher schon. Also die Zugriffsmöglichkeit ist da und jetzt kommen wir halt in diese nächste Problematik rein. Wir haben das jetzt mit der Gesichtserkennung jetzt schon auch diskutiert. Kameras sind billig, Algorithmen sind billig,
dieses Machine Learning wird in zunehmendem Maße billig, sowohl was das,
Anwenden fertiger Training Sets betrifft, also wo die Daten schon einmal durchgenudelt wurden, als auch das Trainieren selber wird in zunehmendem Maße billig. Wir werden mit Mikrofonen und anderen Sensoriken noch sehr viel mehr sehen. Unstoppable.
Ja, und ich glaube, vor allen Dingen ist ja auch wirklich so Datensammeln und Information über Menschen sammeln einfach ein Geschäftsmodell.
Also gerade wenn wir irgendwie so über targeted advertising oder so sprechen, ist das ein Geschäftsmodell. Und also ein Großteil der Tech-Konzerne funktioniert einfach basierend darauf, dass
es extreme Datenmengen über alle möglichen Personen anhäuft und weiterverkauft und irgendwie,
um alles noch weiter zu personalisieren und dass das auch irgendwie für viele Benutzerinnen,
die sich da ja auch sehr machtlos einfach dem Gegenüber fühlen. Und um jetzt noch mal sozusagen den Kreis zu schließen, hätte ich fast gesagt, zu mehr Überwachungswille durch Regierungen und Co.,
da ist es ja natürlich auch immer so, dass wir haben natürlich mehr Technologie und die Argumentation von von Straferfolgungsbehörden ist natürlich, Technologie macht ihren Job schwieriger,
also im Sinne von kriminell können können sich besser verstecken und deswegen brauchen sie auch
noch mehr Technologie, um Leute zu überwachen und da haben wir ja sozusagen, das ist ja sozusagen
die Problematik, vor der wir regelmäßig stehen und dass das nicht ganz der Realität entspricht.
Und sich Ermittlungsbehörden häufig auch einfach ein bisschen dumm anstellen, steht, glaube ich, auch völlig außer Frage.
Wie die Bundeswehr zum Beispiel.
Aber es ist doch toll, dass die Bundeswehr mit so viel moderner Innovationskraft...
Meinst du vielleicht, dass sie da einen Praktikanten drauf abgesetzt haben und der dann immer das
Netz durchsuchen musste?
Ich denke, das ist der Grund, warum wir jetzt den Innovationspreis bekommen haben auf der CES. Die Bundeswehr, das musst du dir mal vorstellen, durch den innovativen Einsatz moderner Forschungs- und Aufklärungstechniken,
wie das ja im Militär-Jargon heißt, ist es ihnen gelungen, die Existenz und Aktivität,
einer öffentlich agierenden Künstlergruppe, die vor dem Bundestag in Bundeswehr-Tarnfarben.
Das war's für heute.
In originalen Bundeswehrschriftzügen eine Aktion durchführt, darauf zu kommen. Das ist doch Laser-Gehörne.
Also Wahnsinn.
Ich finde alles raus.
Die finden alles raus. Das ist einfach unglaublich. Bundeswehr. Also, Hammer.
Also ja, und ich glaube, das ist natürlich auch total wichtig, weil sonst wären die da nie drauf gekommen.
Und wo sollten sie dann ihre Waffen abgeben?
Ja, und woher sollten die wissen, dass das nur eine Kunstaktion ist?
Ja, das kommt noch dazu.
Also das Zentrum Politischer Schönheit ist ja sowieso gemeinhin bekannt als gefährlich.
Gefährlich, aber jetzt halt auch der Bundeswehr bekannt. Dank künstlicher Intelligenz.
Ja, ich meine, ich rede ja sonst immer über EU-Sachen. Ist dir eigentlich schon aufgefallen, dass ich noch gar nicht viel zur Chatkontrolle gesagt habe heute?
Ja, ist mir aufgefallen. Ich mache ja auch schon immer so Striche. Für jeden 5 Minuten.
Sehr gut. Aber wir haben, glaube ich, habt ihr jemals überhaupt in Logbuchnetzpolitik,
überhaupt schon mal über die UN gesprochen? Das würde mich tatsächlich mal interessieren. Als solche meinst du? Ja, so generell ist das irgendwie mal Thema gewesen.
Als solche meinst du? Gute Frage, kann schon sein. Also bestimmt über einzelne Organisationen,
aber jetzt nicht unbedingt über die UN als solche.
Ja, lass uns doch mal über die UN sprechen.
Okay.
Total überraschende Einleitung. Ich übe noch.
Wir haben auf EU-Ebene ja häufig Gesetzgebungen, die sehr ärgerlich sind,
aber Überraschung, nicht nur die EU kann problematische Gesetzgebung machen, auch,
die UN kann problematische Gesetzgebung machen und das ist dann halt auch wirklich noch ein
bisschen schlimmer, weil die UN hat rund 193 Mitgliedstaaten, das heißt, das betrifft dann,
nicht nur die EU, sondern alle und diesmal, der ein oder die andere hat das vielleicht schon gesehen geht es um das UN Cybercrime Treaty.
Das Thema der Cybercrime Convention hatte ja Thomas schon angesprochen vor zwei Sendungen, drei Sendungen.
Genau. Vielleicht noch mal als Refresher. Das UN Cybercrime Treaty wird derzeit verhandelt.
Es wird schon seit einem Jahr verhandelt und wird auch noch ein Jahr weiter verhandelt werden. Die Verhandlungen dazu finden in New York und in Wien statt.
Und das ist tatsächlich eines der ersten Male, dass zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen bei so einer Verhandlung mit am Tisch sitzen, unter anderem auch Epicenter Works und das ist
tatsächlich diesmal ein etwas größeres Team. Tanja aus dem Team von Epicenter Works hat da auch bereits jetzt schon vorgetragen. Ich denke mal, Thomas wird auch irgendwie mal in der Zukunft
mal darüber berichten, wie das eigentlich so ist, so was in der UN zu verhandeln. Das ist dann noch mal ein bisschen was anderes als in der EU. Was noch nicht so detailliert besprochen wird,
es wurde es halt, also außer dass es echt problematisch werden könnte, wenn dieses
Treaty so kommt, wie es gerade aussieht, was da uns eigentlich erwartet. Also grundsätzlich ist
ist es halt eine Konvention zu Cybercrime. Und es soll halt geklärt werden, was Cybercrime ist,
aber auch welche Instrumente genutzt werden sollen, um Cybercrime zu bekämpfen. Und derzeit
gibt es so erste Entwürfe, die herumgehen und die sind noch nicht final. Wie gesagt.
Die Verhandlungen gehen noch ein Jahr. Das ist mehr so eine Wunschliste der Staaten, was sie
eigentlich gerne so in diesem Cybercrime-Treaty drin hätten. Und das ist ziemlich beunruhigend,
was da drin steht. Also zum einen wollen sie bestimmte Tatbestände festlegen, darunter zum
Beispiel den illegalen Zugriff auf Computersysteme, das illegale Abfangen
von Daten, den widerrechtlichen Zugriff auf Computersysteme, Störung von Computersystemen oder Daten und den Missbrauch von Geräten und Programmen.
Oh, dass da mal einer mal was macht.
Das kommt uns irgendwie bekannt vor.
Ja, ja, ich beobachte viele Leute dabei, wie sie Missbrauch an ihren Geräten vornehmen und auch an ihrer Software. Das ist ganz furchtbar. Das muss wirklich mal in Riegel vorgeschoben werden.
Naja, aber ich meine, das ist irgendwie so klassisch, wenn wir irgendwie über so Cybercrime
sprechen, dass das alles Sachen sind, die so vage formuliert sind, dass das eine extreme Unsicherheit, also eine Unsicherheit, die ja sowieso schon für viele IT-Sicherheitsforscherinnen da ist, aber eine noch größere Unsicherheit für IT-Sicherheitsforscherinnen darstellt.
Also das ist schon mal so der erste Teil, wo man so sagt, so okay, ein Hackerparagraf für die UN. Das ist bestimmt eine sehr gute Idee. Und dann auch wirklich noch so, dass dann auch,
entsprechend dafür sorgen könnten, dass komplette Strafgesetzbücher geändert werden. Also wenn so ein
UN-Treaty beschlossen wird, dafür braucht es übrigens eine Zweidrittelmehrheit der Staaten, und dann müssen die Staaten das natürlich noch in ihrer nationalen Gesetzgebung ratifizieren. Und,
dann würde das halt umgesetzt werden. Und das kann natürlich dann auch noch zu weiteren Auslegungsdingen führen. Und was aber sehr interessant ist, ist, dass sie sich ja nicht,
nur auf Straftaten einigen wollen. Sie wollen damit einfach einen globalen Standard schaffen,
mit dem Internetkriminalität bekämpft wird. Und sie wollen vor allen Dingen auch ein globales,
Tooling schaffen, um Internetkriminalität zu bekämpfen. Vielleicht bewirbt sich ja die
Bundeswehr dann mit ihrem Propaganda-Awareness-Projekt, mit KI natürlich.
Mit KI.
Das ist das, was wir als Kompanieintelligenz sind.
Ich sage doch, das waren die Praktikanten. Nein, aber halt angedacht werden halt
auch solche Sachen wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung als Ermittlungstool,
gegen globalen Cybercrime und man will dann natürlich auch, was natürlich total
wichtig ist, ist natürlich nicht nur, dass man Tooling hat, was alle gleich benutzen können,
sondern dass natürlich auch alle auf alle Daten zugreifen können. Und das ist ein riesen Problem. In Europa gibt es das E-Evidenz-Gesetz und in den USA gibt es den sogenannten Cloud Act. Und das ist
halt bisher so, dass man immer bestimmte Abkommen braucht, damit jetzt zum Beispiel die deutsche Polizei auf polnische Server zum Beispiel zugreifen kann. Das heißt, die müssen dann
entweder eine bestimmte Abstimmung haben, also das EU-Evidenzgesetz würde das zum Beispiel erlauben,
dass es ein EIL-Verfahren gibt und dass man dann halt auf Daten, auf Servern in einem anderen
Land zugreifen kann und ähnliches ist auch mit dem Cloud Act. Und das wollen die sozusagen mit
diesem EU-Cybercrime-Treaty ausweiten. Das heißt, dass das dann halt auch einfach einen schnelleren Austausch, aber natürlich auch dieses ganze Thema.
Dinge sperren und vom Netz nehmen, auch sozusagen beschleunigen.
Und das ist natürlich, kann man jetzt wieder so ein bisschen so ein Bogen zur Contentmoderation machen, in vielen Fällen sehr problematisch, wenn so was im Eilverfahren passiert. Und bisher ist da auch überhaupt noch keine rechtsstaatliche
Garantie dafür, dass die betroffenen Rechte eingehalten werden, da natürlich sich die nationalen Gesetzgebungen von allen UN-Mitgliedern dann doch sehr unterscheiden und natürlich,
auch die Einspruchsmöglichkeiten viel, viel schwieriger sind, wenn Ermittlungsbehörden aus einem anderen Land dafür sorgen, dass irgendwas mit deinem Server passiert.
Also ich finde das schwierig. Ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es eigentlich irgendetwas anderes, was auf UN-Ebene schon mal so geregelt worden ist, was so eine globale Anwendung finden soll?
Weil das scheint mir so ein bisschen auch so eine neue Art von Vorstoß zu sein. Das einzige, was mir jetzt irgendwie einfallen würde, wäre sowas wie Weltraumrecht oder sowas. In irgendeiner Form für...
Ja, und wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Klimaziele.
Ja, Klimaziele, die aber jetzt ja eigentlich ja auch immer alles nur so Versprechenseinsammlungen.
Ja, natürlich. Aber um nochmal auf die Historie der UN zurückzugehen, die wurde 1945 gegründet, um den Weltfrieden zu wahren.
Die grundlegenden Ziele sind Frieden und Sicherheit, deswegen ist auch der Cybercrime Treaty da angehängt. Menschenrechte, Umwelt und Klima und ökonomische Entwicklung.
Ich würde davon ausgehen, dass es schon das eine oder andere Abkommen gab, das Dinge maßgeblich festgehalten hat.
Aber im digitalen Raum hat das natürlich auch eine extreme Auswirkung, weil wir es mit extrem komplexen Problemen zu tun haben,
aber auch mit extrem unterschiedlichen Nationen, was ihren Umgang mit solchen Dingen angeht.
Ja, all right. So viel dazu, da müssen wir halt noch mal ein bisschen abwarten, was sich da in Zukunft zu tut.
Ja, also wie gesagt, UN Cybercrime Treaty, super problematisch.
Bei den Überwachungsinstrumenten habe ich für jeden Fall die Aufzählung vergessen, das ist übrigens auch staatliches Hacking.
Also das werden wir weiter kritisch beobachten und ich denke, Thomas wird da nochmal vorbeikommen und kann nochmal mehr dazu sagen.
Und wo wir gerade so über noch mehr problematische Gesetzgebungen sprechen. Wir haben ja die Chatkontrolle gewonnen und am Anfang sah es in der Schweiz relativ gut aus,
das Parlament hat gesagt, so hm, das ist eine ziemlich problematische Gesetzgebung, wir müssen irgendwie unsere Bürgerinnen dafür schützen, wenn das in dieser Form kommt. Aber jetzt haben,
sie ein Gesetz beschlossen, das vorsieht, dass im Bereich Filme und Videospiele, also so alles, was so YouTube, Netflix, Twitch, Steam, was auch immer du hast, Age Verification vorgenommen
werden soll. Das heißt Alterskontrolle, bevor du den ganzen Kram benutzen kannst.
Ausweichspflicht im Internet, mal wieder. Und also der einzige Vorschlag, der als Beispiel in,
dieser Gesetzgebung genannt wurde, war, dass man ja eine Kopie von seinem Personalausweis einschicken kann.
Das ist die einzige Idee, auf die sie gekommen ist.
Sonst wurde das nicht eindeutig spezifiziert. Das Ganze lässt sich, das ist ja in der Schweiz
ein bisschen anders als in Deutschland, aber noch durch eine Volksabstimmung stoppen. Die läuft bis,
zum 19. Januar und dafür müssen 50.000 Unterschriften gesammelt werden, also an alle
Hörerinnen, ich weiß nicht, habt ihr Hörerinnen in der Schweiz bestimmt?
Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Nehmt an dieser Volksabstimmung teil, weil ansonsten sieht das ziemlich schlecht aus und es ist halt
auch wieder so, wenn es ein Land macht, dann machen es alle anderen nach, weil könnte ja funktionieren.
Also, Age Verification bleibt ein Thema und da begegnen wir im Zweifelsfall auch wieder diesem ganzen Biometriethema. Ich glaube, ich hatte es in der letzten Folge, in der ich zu Besuch war,
schon mal erzählt. Also in Großbritannien entsteht ein ganzer Markt an Start-ups,
die Altersverifikationen mit Hilfe von Machine Learning und biometrischen Daten macht. Auch das,
halt wieder hochgradig problematisch, vor allen Dingen, wenn es um die biometrischen Daten von
jungen Menschen geht und die auf Sachen nicht mehr zugreifen können, die für sie halt in ihrem
Leben elementar sind, würde ich mal so sagen.
Ja, vor allem, ich meine, kaum jemand ist kreativer dabei, so was zu umgehen wie Jugendliche.
Also ich kann nur sagen, viel Spaß. Das wird bestimmt super funktionieren.
Das hat ja mit den, wie ist das bei Zigarettenautomaten gewesen, Kreditkarten an Zigarettenautomaten oder so, auch wunderbar funktioniert.
Ja, Perso und so. Oh, mein Lieblingsthema.
Aber wollen wir nicht mal irgendwie über was Schönes sprechen? Dein Lieblingsthema?
Ja, ich dachte, das ist doch, also ich habe immer das Gefühl, das ist total dein Lieblingsthema.
Also zumindest auf jeden Fall ein Thema für mich gerade, sagen wir es mal so.
Die Rede ist von...
Ja, Chat-GPT. Hast du es denn inzwischen hingekriegt? Seid ihr jetzt Freunde geworden?
Freunde ist ein großes Wort. Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, mit Chet GPT sich zu unterhalten, ist so ein bisschen.
Wie so ein völlig von sich überzeugter Turbonerd irgendwie im Zugriff zu haben, der 80 Prozent aller Fragen, die man stellt, halbwegs akkurat beantwortet.
20 Prozent nicht, aber es ist nicht sofort klar, was die 20 Prozent sind und was zu den
80 Prozent gehört. Also man muss sozusagen so ein gesundes Misstrauen, aber auch ein gewisses Wohlwollen mitbringen. um dann so abschätzen zu können, welche der Empfehlungen jetzt wirklich wertvoll ist
oder was einfach nur so daher fabuliert ist.
Ja, also meine Lieblingsgeschichte ist ja, ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast,
dass das ChatGPT Buchtitel generiert zu Autoren, die es tatsächlich gibt,
aber die Buchstitter gibt es nicht.
Ja, ja und ich meine, wer jetzt noch nicht genau weiß, wovon wir reden, wir hatten es wie gesagt vor ein, zwei Sendungen schon mal, also von OpenAI, von diesem Start-up gibt es,
halt verschiedene beeindruckende Systeme, unter anderem diesen Bildgenerator Dolly und so weiter.
Es gibt da Whisper, die Spracherkennung und jetzt eben auch dieses Chat-GPT, was eben versucht,
diese Kontextualisierung einzubringen. Und das gelingt schon ganz gut. Man weiß natürlich jetzt nicht so richtig, auf welchen Daten letzten Endes der ganze Kram wirklich basiert. Also,
Sie haben halt verschiedenste Systeme dort mit reingenommen und es ist teilweise schon erstaunlich, was man so bekommen kann.
Es ist ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, es ist jetzt ganz toll weil oder es ist ganz,
scheiße weil, sondern man merkt so richtig, da ist so ein Werkzeug im Werden gerade, was einfach einen gewissen Appeal hat. Also es ist ganz offensichtlich nicht nutzlos, aber es ist auch ganz offensichtlich nicht Allwissend!
Ja, und ich glaube, das ist irgendwie so, das ist irgendwie am Anfang meistens total lustig,
mit solchen Sachen rumzuspielen, aber sie sind halt auch immer nur so gut wie die Daten, mit denen sie trainiert wurden und die sind halt auch so, nö, immer den Querschnitt des Internets.
Also entweder sind die Daten nicht gut oder die Trainingsmodelle sind halt noch nicht gut genug aus diesen Daten hervorgegangen.
Also das ist ja immer so die Frage, was nimmt man denn da raus? Und klar, ich meine, ich weiß nicht, was du für Erfahrungen gesammelt hast.
Ich habe es jetzt vor allem versucht, Fragen zu stellen. Also es gibt so bestimmte Sachen, die lassen sich einfach schwer googeln.
Das hat damit zu tun, dass es halt Begriffe verwendet, die für was ganz anderes stehen. Keine Ahnung, versuch mal nach irgendwas zu suchen und irgendein Popstar heißt so.
Dann ist irgendwie schon alles vorbei.
Du kriegst es also sehr schwer kontextualisiert, dass du das eine Problem hast.
Und das andere ist, du findest zwar viel Information über A und du findest viele Informationen über B, aber du findest dann keinerlei Informationen, die das eine mit dem anderen in Relation setzen.
Solchen Nachfragen hatte ich ganz interessante Ergebnisse, dass ich wirklich sagen konnte, so was ist der Unterschied zwischen dem und dem und da ist dann dem Tool tatsächlich teilweise
gelungen, da etwas herauszudistillieren, was mir weitergeholfen hat.
Also Googlen ist natürlich auch irgendwie so eine Wissenschaft für sich und dann hast du natürlich auch noch den Hit an Menschen, die sich mit SEO-Optimierungen beschäftigen, die dann auch noch einen Impact darauf haben.
Ja, und das hat auch mal für Alarm gesorgt bei Google, weil das das allererste Mal so wirklich wahrscheinlich in ihrer Geschichte ist, dass irgendwie ihr Businessmodel mal in Frage gestellt wird. Und Google hat halt wirklich anscheinend Angst vor Verlust von Nutzerinnen.
Und Personen sind häufiger mit Chat-GPT-Antworten zufriedener als mit Google-Suchergebnissen.
Und jetzt plant Google natürlich auch irgendwie ein Konkurrenzprodukt in irgendeiner Art und
Weise dazu zu schaffen, was ich sehr interessant finde. Und auch sehr gespannt bin, wie es weitergeht, während Microsoft, die ja jetzt nicht unbedingt dafür bekannt sind, der größte Sucherschiedenanbieter der Welt zu sein, versucht Bing.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du schon mal Bing benutzt?
Ich habe schon mal Bing benutzt, aber es ist schon eine Weile her, dass ich das letzte Mal benutzt habe.
Okay, also ich hab glaube ich noch nie Bing benutzt, deswegen weiß ich überhaupt gar nicht, wie das aussieht und wie sich das anfühlt.
Du hast nichts verpasst, ne? Ja, nee.
Ist das nicht als Default-Suchmaschine im Internet Explorer früher eingestellt gewesen?
Das kann gut sein, dass das auf Windows der Fall ist, aber ich glaube, Internet-Explorer gibt es nicht mehr. Das heißt jetzt anders, das heißt jetzt Edge.
Na ja, aber egal. Auf jeden Fall ist alles gleich schlimm.
Auf jeden Fall hat Microsoft ja schon sehr viel Geld in OpenAI, also in die Firma, die
die ChatGPT gebaut hat, auch zu einem sehr frühen Zeitpunkt investiert.
Seitdem versuchen sie Bing, also ihre Suchmaschine, sowieso schon,
oder da fließt schon relativ viel Technik von früheren ChatGPT-Entwicklungen mit ein. Jetzt wollen sie sozusagen ein neues Produkt launchen,
ein Bing, was mit ChatGPT getunt wurde.
Ich bin da sehr gespannt. Ich bin auch sehr gespannt, wie Sie das von der Leistung machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es auch schon hattest, aber immer mehr Leute haben das Ding so, dass Chat-GPT gerade nicht benutzbar ist ressourcentechnisch, weil...
Ja klar, weil sich die ganze Welt gerade drauf stürzt und das eben schon eine gewisse ressourcenintensive Anwendung ist,
was sich nicht so ohne weiteres mal mit irgendeinem gut gemachten Index erschlagen lässt. Also, ich habe ja keine Ahnung, wie komplex mittlerweile diese ganze Suchabfragen-Geschichte bei Google so funktioniert.
Das ist ja auch nicht ohne.
Aber es ist halt nicht so, dass jetzt über jeden String, den du da eingibst, irgendwie intensiv mit vielen Computern nachgedacht werden muss.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das nur so ein Ding ist bei ChattGPT, dass sie diesen Text so langsam ausgeben.
Das hat ja totale 80er-Jahre-Vibes für mich. Weil so war das früher, als wir mit Telekommunikation angefangen haben,
und die Modems nur so 300 Bit pro Sekunde übertragen haben.
Vielleicht passt dich das aber auch an seine Nutzerin an.
Wieso, geht es bei dir schneller oder was?
Skandal.
Muss ich mal die Age Verification irgendwie nochmal anders einstellen.
Na ja, aber vielleicht ist es so, dass es nicht so an deine...
Also, wer das schon mal benutzt hat, wenn das gesehen haben, man tippt was ein und man kriegt auch eine Antwort. Aber die Antwort malt sich so in Lesegeschwindigkeit so in etwa auf den Bildschirm.
Also man kann wirklich den Buchstaben noch dabei zusehen, wie sie so, also nicht Buchstabe für Buchstabe, ich sag mal so Wort für Wort auf dem Bildschirm erscheint.
Teilweise auch ganz interessant, dass das Ding auch so Sätze nachträglich ändert.
Also man sieht so richtig, wie es sich grammatikalisch so herausschält und eigentlich erst am Ende,
des Satzes weiß, wie der ganze Satz sein soll. Also das ist zumindest der Eindruck, den ich gewinne. Ich habe natürlich keine Ahnung, wie das mit Detail funktioniert und ich finde das auch alles
ziemlich beeindruckende Technologie, so oder so. Weil das ist halt, Chat-GPT ist wirklich wieder
so ein Ding, womit dieser Spruch einfällt. Ich weiß nicht, von wem war der nochmal. Keine Ahnung, das ist irgendwie, also jede Technologie, die so einigermaßen über deinen Horizont hinausgeht, lässt dich von Zauberrei nicht unterscheiden. So das irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie ich es gerade,
zitiert habe, aber nicht wörtlich. Aber so kommt einem das herüber, weil man auf einmal etwas ganz anderes bekommt aus dem Internet, als man das bisher oder von seinem Computer, als man das bisher,
so kannte. Du kannst aber dich hingehen und sagen, ich möchte gerne ein Kurzbühnenstück haben mit,
irgendwie einem silbernen Hasen und irgendwie einer Fußgängerampel, die sich irgendwie über
die Qualität von Hamburger unterhalten. Und dann kommt da irgendwas bei raus. Das macht.
Vielleicht in dem Moment keinen Sinn, aber es ist auf jeden Fall totale Zauberei. Lange,
Rede kurzer Sinn. Es macht viel Sinn, dieser Technologie weiter nachzugehen für jemanden, der behauptet, einem den Zugang zu den Informationen der Welt zu liefern. Das ist ja so ein bisschen
das, was bei Google drunter steht, nachdem sie dieses Don't Be Evil eingelassen haben. Evil können wir schon sein, aber trotzdem Informationen des Internets machen wir euch zugänglich.
Nur halt nicht mehr so gut, nur ein bisschen böse.
Ja, klar, macht total Sinn und ich denke mal auch dieses Thema mit der Rechenleistung,
die aktuell wahrscheinlich noch relativ kostenintensiv ist, wird sich wahrscheinlich so Moorsh Law einfach geben.
Wird sich ändern, genau.
Ja, also ich bin sehr gespannt und ich bin auch gespannt, was das so mit den nächsten Generationen macht.
Und generell mit diesem ganzen Konstrukt von Suchmaschinen.
Und das hat auch Value. Also dieses Suchen ist ja irgendwie in gewisser Hinsicht billig.
Niemand ist wirklich jetzt groß bereit für so eine Internetsuche Geld auszugeben. Deswegen geht das alles über Werbung.
Aber ChatGPT ist so ein Dienst, wo ich sagen würde, also wenn das jetzt morgen schon nicht mehr da wäre und ich bin jetzt schon angefixt,
Ja, weil es wirklich, also es ist wirklich, da kommt teilweise wirklich hanebüchener Unsinn dabei raus. Und wie du schon sagtest, irgendwas wird so erfunden. Du sagst, vergleiche die Theorie von dem Philosophen und dem Philosophen.
Dann kommt da so ein Gewäsch bei raus und das liest du dir durch und denkst du so, aber wenn du irgendwie Ahnung von Philosophie hast, merkst du, dass da irgendwo so was ganz Grundsätzliches verwechselt wurde. Andererseits, bei manchen Fragen,
kommen absolut akurate Zusammenfassungen. Also ich habe jetzt, das Thema ist ja gerade Hausaufgaben. Da dachte ich mir so, okay, dann benutze ich das doch mal für Hausaufgaben. Da kommt dann dieses...
Machst du die Hausaufgaben von deinen Kindern?
Hahaha.
Jetzt kommt das raus.
Einer muss es ja machen.
Immer diese Helikoptereltern, die so übermotiviert sind. Also du weißt schon, dass das nicht gut ist, wenn du die Hausaufgaben machst.
Das Problem ist, Hausaufgaben sind das Peinlichste, was es gibt für Eltern, weil die Kinder
kommen immer an und sagen, hier, das ist unsere Aufgabe, ich verstehe das nicht. Dann schaust du drauf und stellst fest, keine Ahnung, habe ich alles vergessen. Weiß ich auch nicht, habe ich nicht gelernt, keine Ahnung, so was schaut ihr euch an.
Dann haben wir dann halt auch wie so, ja, hier irgendwie, was ist denn mit dem Ancien Regime, französische Revolution und wie denn das alles so gelaufen ist.
Klar, die haben halt ihr Lehrbuch, dann sind da so 3, 4, 5 Textseiten, die sollen sich durchlesen, irgendwie verinnerlichten, dann zusammenfassen, wunderbar. So, aber ich konnte,
dann erstmal irgendwie erstmal gar nichts fragen, das ist mir so, frag ich doch mal,
Chat-GBT. Und Chat-GBT hat mir dann halt über die französische Revolution so einiges ausgespuckt und ich habe es dann im Nachgang auch nochmal mit diesen Textbüchern verglichen, so. Und,
das war schon mal, also es war eine sehr hilfreiche Zusammenstellung. Dann kriegste da so 1, 2, vier fünf Punkte so, was war das Problem, was führte zur Französischen Revolution.
Irgendwas mit Brot und Kuchen, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, aber halt auch so die Kriege, die Frankreich mit den anderen Ländern führten, wirtschaftliche
Situationen, Pipapo, dieses und jenes, einfach so Aspekte, die gerade wenn es so darum geht, so was wie im Deutschunterricht, wo es ja auch immer so ein bisschen darum geht, so die.
Gesamtsituationen verstehen, interpretieren, Bewegungsgründe formulieren und auch Formulierungen
zu finden und Worte auch zu finden. Man macht ja viel daran fest, dass so was wie Chat-GPT jetzt nicht geeignet ist, weil die Fakten stimmen nicht. Na gut, dann lässt du halt,
die Fakten raus und kümmere dich nur um die Form. Du kannst das Ding ja auch benutzen mit hier schreibe ich dir die Fakten Stichpunkt für Stichpunkt hin, mach mir einen schönen Text
da draus, der irgendwie in blumiger romantischer Sprache mit etwas Humor diesen Sachverhalt
wiedergibt. So, und das kannst du ja dann selber auch bewerten, ob dieser Sachverhalt okay zurückgegeben wurde, aber dir ist unter Umständen eine andere Sprache gegeben worden, die dich in dem Moment inspiriert. Und das ist mein Punkt.
Ich glaube, dass das Tool vor allem derzeit für so Glücksrecherchen ganz gut ist, dass irgendwas versuchst, rauszufinden, was einfach so mit Google und anderen Quellen...
Also entweder musst du viel zu viel lesen oder es ist halt so viel Nebel vor dieser
Information, durch die so eine Suchmaschine nicht durchkommt. Aber wenn es darum geht, einen inspirieren zu lassen, ist es halt wirklich teilweise gut.
Von einem habe ich gesehen, der hat CheckKPT einfach gefragt so, ja mach mir mal ein paar Vorschläge wie man seine Wohnung einrichten kann.
Das ist natürlich wieder total interessant für Targeted Advertising.
Und das ist ja auch das, was Suchmaschinen so interessant macht,
dass Leute den Suchmaschinen sehr genau sagen, was sie gerne kaufen wollen und was sie suchen.
Und ChatGPT, weil sie damit reden, mit ChatGPT auch reden wie mit einem Menschen in Zweifelsfall und sagen ich habe eine leere weiße Wand. Was soll ich damit tun?
Das geile war, die Antworten, die chat.gpt dann auf diese Wohnungseinrichtungsfrage.
Und dann irgendwie so weiß ich nicht, was ist ein großer Anbieter für irgendwie Kunst, es slidet so direkt in deine DMs.
Also das ist ja wirklich so ein Thema, was natürlich ein Geschäftsmodell für die Zukunft,
die auf jeden Fall ist.
Gegeben hat und zwar eins zu eins so, wie das aus Chat-GPT rauskam, also den Text sozusagen copy-paste, dann in Mid Journey, das ist so diese Discord-basierte Social-Network für
AI-erzeugte Bilder, also so ähnlich wie Dolly, aber sozusagen wo so eine ganze Community dann immer noch mitarbeitet und aus diesen Beschreibungen kamen so super awesome Bilder
raus, wie diese Wohnung eingerichtet war. Also das war wirklich einfach stunning. Ich hab mir gesagt, wie krass ist das bitte. Also es sah einfach wirklich hervorragend aus.
Und das sind so Prozesse, glaube ich, die wir jetzt sehen werden. Also wir haben jetzt hier
eine Technologie, die sehr viel Fallout hat, wo sich viele darüber aufregen und viel über diese Wahrheit und was steckt da sozusagen und Wahrheit drin unterhalten werden. Aber auch so was bei rauskommen kann.
Ich glaube, klar, da kann sowas bei rauskommen.
Ich glaube, man sollte es halt irgendwie immer mit so eine Grain of
Salt nehmen und gerade bei allem, was irgendwie daten-AI-basiert ist, ist es einfach so, dass wir da halt auch immer einen gewissen Bias mit drin haben,
und auch irgendwie eine gewisse Intransparent wie diese Modelle einfach zu ihren Entscheidungen kommen.
Und das ist, glaube ich, einfach nur was, nicht nur. Das ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was man kritisch beobachten muss, aber ich glaube, über Regulierung für ein AI haben wir jetzt auch schon ausreichend gesprochen.
Also ich habe jetzt mal gefragt, ich habe eine große weiße Wand, was soll ich damit machen?
Es gibt viele Möglichkeiten, was Sie mit einer großen weißen Wand machen können. Einige Ideen sind, malen Sie die Wand in einer Farbe, vor allem um einen Akzent zu setzen. Hängen Sie ein großes Wandbild oder eine Galerie von Bildern auf, um die Wand zu dekorieren. Da bist du bestimmt noch nicht drauf gekommen, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, hier war so ein Mittelalter Typ, der mir erklärt hat, was ich mit weißen Wänden machen kann.
Also bisher muss ich sagen, die Antworten sind vielfältig, aber irgendwie noch nichts.
Die Antwort war übrigens nicht so schön.
Nein. Nein, aber das ist halt wieder genau das, was du gerade vorgelesen hast.
Besonderes dabei. Memo, Bird, Memo Board, Magnethafen, Projektionsfläche. Also das bringt dich nicht wirklich weiter, glaube ich.
Könnte ihre Werbung stehen.
Ja, also es ist natürlich ein Privacy-Aspekt hier mit drin. Also man vertraut sich solchen Systemen dann unter Umständen noch mal auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise an, vielleicht.
Das wird spannend sein, das zu verfolgen.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, hast du dir mal die Datenschutzerklärung von von TGPT angeguckt? Weiß ich nicht. Also das wird mich halt schon interessieren, was
die so... also die werden sicherlich alle Eingaben nutzen, um das Ding weiter zu trainieren.
Also das steht ja völlig außer Frage. Ich meine, das verbessert sich ja auch selber und so, wenn man kritisch nachfragt. Aber das wäre ja schon mal irgendwie... also hat und irgendwie noch keiner drüber, habe ich noch nichts drüber gelesen.
Also ich habe auf jeden Fall wird glaube ich derzeit nichts gespeichert.
Warte mal, ich kann ja mal den Chat-Gap einfach fragen. Speicherst du irgendwelche Daten von mir
oder bleibt etwas von diesem Dialog auf deinen Servern erhalten?
Als AI-Modell speichere ich keine persönlichen Daten von Benutzern und alle Daten, die im Zusammenhang mit unserem Dialog stehen, werden auf unserem Server nicht gespeichert.
Der Dialog wird in Echtzeit verarbeitet und nach Beendigung des Gesprächs gelöscht.
Ich bin darauf programmiert, ihre Anfragen zu verstehen und darauf zu antworten, ohne dabei ihre Daten zu speichern oder zu teilen.
Also die machen Live-Analyse, das ist ein bisschen anders als das, was unsere Bundesregierung macht.
Bundeswehr macht bestimmt total krasse Sachen damit.
Also die machen Live-Analyse, damit sie aus den Datenschutzfragen rauskommen. Unsere Bundesregierung macht keine Live-Analyse, damit sie danach mehr Daten haben, die sie analysieren können.
Ja, und ich meine, das ist jetzt eine Aussage von JetGPT, also das ist wahr.
Ja, und das ist natürlich auch irgendwie was darüber, wo man reden muss.
Menschen tendieren natürlich dazu, Aussagen von Computern als total objektiv und wahr einzuordnen und es auch nicht so viel zu hinterfragen an einigen Stellen.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Problem, mit dem man dann da zu tun hat. Also ja, es bleibt spannend.
Ich frage nochmal, darf ich das glauben?
Als künstliche Intelligenz habe ich keine Fähigkeit zu lügen oder Tatsachen zu verbergen. Ich bin programmiert, um auf Anfragen mit Informationen zu antworten, die ich aufgrund meiner Schulung kenne. Ich kann Ihnen versichern, dass ich keine persönlichen Datenspeicherungen auch nicht teile.
Ich komme mir so ein bisschen vor, wie so ein Science-Fiction-Film.
Und es ist auch irgendwie so im Negativen, weil eigentlich unterstützt, also haben Sie das Ding, die Antwort ja genauso geschrieben, wie das, was ich gerade gesagt habe, nämlich so, ich bin ein Computer, ich habe kein Bias.
Ja, ist das so ein bisschen wie 2001. eins. Ich bin einer der größten Meinungen, die jemals programmiert worden sind.
Ja, aber was ist denn das großartigste Produkt, was in der Corona-Pandemie programmiert wurde,
Tim. Das ist nämlich noch besser und noch kostenintensiver als D-Mail. Wusstest du das?
Jetzt kommen wir zu den richtigen Start-ups.
Was ist das denn? Echt? Kosten intensiver oder kosten effektiver?
Wie viel kostet denn eine D-Mail? Ja wie teuer, weißt du das noch?
Wie viel kostet denn eine? Ich glaube, Linus hat das mal die Zahl feingelassen, aber ich kann mir das irgendwie nicht...
Ich kann mir Chat gebeten. Warum?
Ist D-Mail der Grund, warum Deutschland Innovations-Champion geworden ist?
Nein, wir sind natürlich Infektions-Champion. Infektions-Champion sind wir nicht geworden, aber Innovations-Champion sind wir natürlich
geworden wegen der Luca-App. Also machen wir uns nichts vor. Und ich meine, wir wissen ja, dass Behörden langsam malen und dass das dann auch alles irgendwie Geld kostet, aber Luca sollte das ja vereinfachen.
Und ja, wie kostenintensiv ist so eine Kontaktnachverfolgung eigentlich?
Ziemlich, weil es findet gar nicht so viel statt für den Preis, steht sich raus.
Ach so, aber ich dachte also, die Fallzeit, also jetzt bin ich verwirrend. Gab es so eine geringe
Userbasis.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, welche Zahlen Luca am Ende erreicht hat, aber auf jeden Fall, zumindest in Brandenburg, gab es wohl mit der Luca-App genau eine erfolgreiche Kontaktnachverfolgung. Das hat nur eine Million Euro gekostet.
Aber ich glaube, dann ist die Kontaktnachverfolgung wirklich teurer als eine einzige D-Mail. Ja, also nicht als das Projekt insgesamt, aber weißt du,
Ich hoffe, es wurde einfach einstellen.
Super. Das war echt ein erfolgreiches Projekt.
Aber wir haben ja davor gewarnt. Aber es hält ja keiner auf die Warnung. Es kommt alles irgendwie wieder zurück. Was auch zurückkommt ist die Trust ID.
Wir brauchen eine Luca-Warn-App. Ja, die TrustPID. Das P steht für Petser. Genau, die TrustPID, bereits Doktbuch Netzpolitik.
Trust PID, Entschuldigung, die Trust PID.
Das P. Der Petsprobe, Alter.
Berichtete in Folge 431. Und es geht voran. Und jetzt haben die Deutsche Telekom Orange, das ist französischer Telefonprovider, Telefonica Spanien und Vodafone UK ein gemeinsames Joint
Venture angekündigt zur Trust PID und die EU-Kommission guckt sich das jetzt nicht etwa
von einer Privacy-Perspektive an, sondern von einer kartellrechtlichen Seite, nämlich ob die das
überhaupt dürfen.
Jetzt sollen wir nochmal kurz erläutern, was die Idee ist.
Das stimmt. Also das Internet ist ja kostenfrei, wissen wir alle.
Das sind halt unendliche Weiten.
Unendliche Werbung. Und wir haben ja vorhin schon so ein bisschen auf die Geschäftsmodelle von Google und Co. angesprochen und die basieren natürlich zu größten Teilen auf Tracking-Systeme und personalisierter Werbung und so weiter und so fort.
Und das ist zum einen aufgrund von irgendwelchen Datenschutzbestimmungen nicht mehr ganz zutreffend.
Und dann gibt es natürlich so böse Menschen wie uns, die irgendwie Cookie-Blocker benutzen,
und das einfach verhindern. Und das ist natürlich ein ganz großes Problem, wenn man keine Werbung mehr machen kann. Und deswegen haben sich jetzt die Provider überlegt, die machen ja noch nicht genügend Geld,
damit das dafür bezahlen, dass wir irgendwie Zugänge zu Internet und Co. haben, dass sie das Problem ja lösen könnten. Und sie möchten jetzt eine sogenannte TrustPay ID entwerfen, die sich immer ergibt aus der IP-Adresse und der Telefonnummer.
Der Nutzerin, wenn man sich mit dem Netz connectet. Und dann gibt es halt diese,
pseudonymisierte ID, die dann entsprechend genutzt werden kann, um
Werbung zu machen.
Tolle Idee.
Total super. Vor allen Dingen total super, dass man auf
Infrastrukturebene dann das verpetzt, vor allen Dingen von einem Anbieter, den
man ja sowieso schon für das Angebot, was er anbietet, bezahlt. Es ist fast genauso gut,
wie die ganze Netzneutralitätsdebatte. Es ist belastend. Ja, belastend. Ich habe noch
nicht über die Stadtkontrolle geredet und ich möchte jetzt unbedingt über die Stadtkontrolle reden.
Okay. Muss es sein.
Ja, ich mache es ganz kurz. Also, die Diskussion geht weiter. Es ist total interessant. Also,
Also die Ratspräsidentschaft in der EU wechselt ja regelmäßig. Und zuletzt war es Tschechien, jetzt ist es Schweden.
Wir dachten alle, naja, wahrscheinlich wird Schweden Chatkontrolle priorisieren, weil,
Elva Johansson eine Schwedin ist und die Chatkontrolle vorgeschlagen hat. Es taucht auf deren Prio-Liste nicht so wirklich auf.
Dennoch gehen die Verhandlungen weiter in der Ratsarbeitsgruppe der Strafverfolgungsbehörden,
Und die Diskussion in Deutschland geht auch weiter. Es ist ja vor Weihnachten dieser Antrag nach Artikel 23 des Grundgesetzes von den Grünen und der FDP bereits veröffentlicht
worden und der würde eine Abstimmung im Bundestag dazu herbeiführen. Der Antrag wird so nicht,
durchgehen. Da fehlt die SPD und da scheitert es maßgeblich an den Menschen, die in der SPD,
sich mit Innen- und Sicherheitspolitik beschäftigen. Da bleibt es also weiterhin spannend. Ja, das war
eigentlich schon.
Das ist das Update zur Check-Kontrolle. Wow, das war kurz. Ja, immerhin.
Dann gab es noch ein Urteil gegen Meta, dafür dass sie die ersten beiden Silben der Metaebene für ihren Namen benutzt haben. Das hat jetzt mehrere Millionen Euro gekostet.
Deswegen kriege ich so viel Geld für diese Folge, ne? Okay.
Ja, habe ich verklagt.
Ja, genau, das ist der Grund. Jetzt schwimmen wir hier im Geld. Nee, stimmt leider nicht, sondern stattdessen wurden sie für ihre, tja, für was denn eigentlich?
390 Millionen Euro müssen Sie zahlen, weil...
Ja, weil sie personenbezogene Werbung machen und ja, also sie benutzen personenbezogene Daten, um Werbung zu machen. Und das steht zwar in den AGBs irgendwie drin, aber der,
Europäische Datenschuss Ausschuss sagt, dass das nicht ausreichend ist, weil eine,
informierte Einwilligung notwendig wäre. So. Und das ist ein Riesenvorstoß. Jetzt können die sich nicht mehr rausreden, was diese Dinge angeht. Und ich bin echt gespannt, was auch,
die Konsequenz für andere Konzerne ist, die mit personenbezogene Daten viel Umsatz machen.
Das ist eigentlich eine echt große Sache, weil im Prinzip greift das ja das Kerngeschäftsmodell
von Meta an und wenn sie jetzt nicht, ich meine, ich weiß nicht, diese 390 Millionen Euro ist wahrscheinlich eine Einmalzahlung, aber das ändert ja nichts daran, dass sie auch weiterhin dafür
in Anspruch genommen werden würden, wenn sie nichts ändern. Also sie müssten ja jetzt auch was ändern. Sprich, wir müssen in Europa zumindest ein Opt-out anbieten aus dieser Verarbeitung. Damit erlauben sie ja sozusagen, also damit entziehen sie sich selbst sozusagen
sagen die Grundlage ihres Geschäftsmodells, wenn genug Leute das machen.
Ja, total. Und diese Opt-out-Geschichte ist ja dann auch wieder so eine Frage, ob es dann einfach dazu führt, dass man das dann halt einfach nur noch schlecht benutzen kann.
Also das ist ja ein sehr häufiger Fall, dass dann die Plattformen einfach nicht mehr gut nutzbar sind. Und das ist ja auch irgendwie immer das absurde Argument, was diese Plattformen anbringen in solchen Zusammenhängen.
Genau, also ganz gute Nachrichten. Und ich glaube, wir haben es geschafft. Und du hast den Gute-Nachricht-Jingle vergessen.
Was war denn jetzt die gute Nachricht?
Na, das mit dem Bußgeld und Demeter-Urteil.
Das mit dem Bußgeld. Achso. Dann holen wir das einfach nochmal nach.
Die gute Nachricht ist jetzt. sind wir schon fast durch. Aber wir haben noch ein paar sonstige Meldungen.
Ja, das stimmt. Und zwar sucht Epicenter Works eine Frontend-Entwicklerin für ein Softwareprojekt. In den nächsten Monaten. Es wird nach Personen gesucht, die sich mit React und,
Vue und Angular und mit Anbindung an REST APIs auskennen. Das Projekt heißt Dear MEP. Es ist,
übrigens ein bezahltes Softwareprojekt und Bewerbung bitte an jobs at epicenter.works.
Unter dem Stichwort Dear MEP. Ich kann euch das sehr ans Herzen legen, die Techies von
MEP Centerworks sind nämlich sehr nett und eventuell fällt dabei auch eine Zusammenarbeit
mit mir raus, aber mehr dann später.
Jetzt wird es aber hot.
Alright. Gut, dann bleibt uns eigentlich nur noch, auf die Termine hinzuweisen.
Am 25.01. findet in Brüssel das jährliche Privacy Camp organisiert von E3 statt.
Das wird sowohl vor Ort als auch hybrid passieren und es gibt sehr viele Vorträge zu digitalen Menschenrechten und weiteren Themen.
Und dann ist auch bald wieder Ostern und Ostern heißt Easter Egg. Also neuerdings heißt das wieder,
weil bisher hieß es ja immer, Easter Egg fällt aus wegen Wissen schon und das ist jetzt, das sieht so aus, als ob das jetzt zum Ende kommt. Wird auch langsam mal Zeit. Also Easter Egg 2023 soll stattfinden. Was ist das? Das ist das Ostertreffen des Chaos Computer Club und der,
wird dieses Mal endlich dann hoffentlich, wie das eben schon seit Ewigkeiten geplant war, in Hamburg stattfinden, nämlich im Kampnagel und ja, das könnte dann umtriebig werden.
29.3. bis 1.4. ist übrigens Ostern. Weiß ja mal, keiner, wann Ostern ist. Ich könnte ein Chat mit dir bitte mal fragen. Achso, du meinst, wegen Easter Egg weiß man jetzt.
Aber alle wissen ja, wann der Easter Hack ist und das ist ja das wirklich Relevante.
Endlich von Ostern ist.
Genau. Und wir kommen auch zur nächsten Gulasch Programmier-Nacht. Die findet nämlich statt vom 8. bis zum 11. Juni in Karlsruhe.
Genau, im ZKM wahrscheinlich wieder. Alles wie immer.
Alles wie immer, das ist die GPN 21.
Das ist eine dramatische Verschiebung der Realitäten. Die waren nämlich so glücklich, dass sie durch irgendeine andere Doppelveranstaltung mal sich aligned haben mit den Jahreszahlen und jetzt wird wieder durchgezählt und jetzt weiß keiner Bescheid.
Also wie auch immer, GPN findet statt und das ist auch schon mal eine gute Nachricht. Alright, gut und die letzte gute Nachricht ist, jetzt sind wir auch durch. Also die Frage ist,
ist das für uns eine gute Nachricht oder ist das eine gute Nachricht für alle oder ist es für Das wird niemanden eine gute Nachricht. Wir werden es nie wissen.
Heute ist nicht alle Tage, ne?
Ja.
Wir kommen wieder, keine Frage. Khaleesi, vielen Dank und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen Dank, dass ihr auch 2023 wieder dabei seid bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
So, und wir haben sicherlich noch ein paar schlechte Nachrichten für euch dieses Jahr,
die wir hier versuchen, in gewohnter Manier zu diskutieren. Oder?
Ja, ich komm vorbei. Ich bin dabei.
Du bist dabei? Schlechte Nachrichten? Du bist dabei. Alles klar. Dann sagen wir Tschüss, bis bald!